so I just got back from a screening of
x-men Days of Future past it's like 2:00
in the morning right now have a great
[ __ ] time but the highlight of my
night I got recognized for the first
time this dude's name is Carlos and I
have to take a picture with him he
didn't ask me for a picture I just
wanted a picture with him so Carlos hey
do it man
I think he's like 15 or something so get
a lot of [ __ ] one day my friend x-men
days of future [ __ ] paths this film
was absolutely incredible without a
doubt this is my most favorite movie of
the year so far so much to talk about
let's get into this one of the first
things I found incredibly impressive
about this film is that it's the biggest
ensemble piece of an x-men movie yet
yeah that's the right choice of words
but somehow they managed to take all
these characters and make everything so
little balanced it's a character driven
sci-fi action drama tell all these
different genres in it it's so [ __ ]
cool and yet some obvious stuff the
visual effects is absolutely great the
action is dynamite
they even amplified the mutant towers to
like another level they introduce new
characters with great powers they took
familiar characters and made their
powers even cooler like every Power I
was like I want that power I want that
power I want that power Austin Powers
really but I guess the main antagonist
of this film is the Sentinels not that
film starring Michael Douglas and Jack
Bauer horrible movie by the way these
are giant robots designed to
specifically hunt down mutants um
annihilate when I first saw the pictures
of them I loved it I was concerned I was
like ah they don't look that scary but I
can honestly tell you these guys terrify
me at times they are a legitimate threat
to these super beings like whenever they
were around I was worried one of the
characters might get killed off and in
an excellent movie you don't really have
that concern but in this you're like
[ __ ] robots robots are gonna destroy
us I know it man technology is the enemy
we got to destroy everything everything
there's one thing movies have taught me
it's that technology is evil [ __ ]
Facebook but if you have a Facebook like
the real rejects page but like I said
the core of this film is really its
characters there's so many of them this
film doesn't feel bombarded though
the right amount of characterization for
each of them they even develop them even
further you actually give a [ __ ] about
like most of them not all them who
really cares about Bishop in this movie
you check off as Wolverine George you
ever get worried that sometimes a
Wolverine is jacking off one of his
claws might come out of next night cut
his penis period but even he'll right
away I mean what can you really say
about Hugh Jackman as Wolverine the
sky's rock-solid
or should I say metal solid that works
he wasn't a tough [ __ ] ever used to
seem as mean sure he's got some of that
too and you know coming off of the
Wolverine this character depiction of it
might feel a little bit you know less
but still he's [ __ ] great this is not
a Wolverine and in samba movie he is
part of the in Samba love you Jackman
you see his ass in this one man because
he's got a great [ __ ] ass I do things
I lick that bundle and I want to say
this is a flaw but I would have liked to
see Wolverine Houston is adamantium
claws at one point in this movie it's
bone claws the entire time still cool
but would have preferred a little bit
man to man to you you think he has a
bone claw that comes out of his penis
what about with the atom Anzio it's like
[ __ ] alien thing with his penis
James McAvoy a returning as young
Charles Xavier this time around is more
like a drug-addicted watched a professor
his journey into rediscovering himself
was beautifully told me sure you know
where he's gonna be by the end of the
film but still it's it's done very well
it's a much more compelling performance
than where we got from him an excellent
burst glass fantastic powerhouse job
James McAvoy yeah hope you continue get
a lot of Scottish [ __ ] my friend
Michael Fassbender is young magneto you
see what brings ass but you don't see
Michael Fassbender's dig this time
around what a shame get it because he
was in a movie called machine I thought
it was great in first class and him and
McAvoy had that incredible chemistry
still damn dude he was so perfect in
this movie he was menacing he was badass
sometimes she kind of feared him
everything they did with his character
this time around was absolutely gripping
this is the best boyfriend I've seen a
magneto yet Michael Fassbender he's so
hot man
damn he's sexy dude I've ever seen his
dick and shame let's just say I got an
erection that is magnitude his penis
it's late guys it's late but honestly my
favorite character has to be Evan Peters
as Quicksilver the dude gets like 20 to
30 minutes of screen time five parties
the most
joyful character out of this Phil he's
cocky yet silly he's funny but he's just
ultra badass seven Peters is perfectly
cast for this role you just want to be
this guy the way they captured his
powers was just like Oh oh my god it was
awesome I've seen gangbang porn before
I've seen like buck to where there's
like 20 guys and one girl and I think
Quicksilver could be all 20 guys and
satisfy the woman Jennifer Lawrence s
mystique I don't know why but I am
really attracted to misty I'm not
talking about Jennifer Lawrence or
Rebecca romaine Stamos when they were
looking like humans I'm talking about
mystique all blue in [ __ ] like she is
flexible as [ __ ] just one point where
she's holding her butt up against a
guy's throat to choke him out and it
she's like doing like a sidekick with it
dude
oh the sex that was running through my
mind I want to get blue balls if you
know what I mean
but here's where I'm sure I'm gonna get
[ __ ] from people I love Jennifer
Lawrence I think she is one of the best
actresses we have around but there's
something about her as mystique that I
never quite fully bought even in first
class I thought you did a better job in
this one but for some reason whenever
she talks I'm like and I'm really buying
it but still she's hot and yeah Jennifer
Lawrence even without looking like
mystique [ __ ] get the hell out of my
bed I don't want to have a relationship
with you they get awesome returning
small performances hot-ass lesbian Ellen
Page is back why are you gay I thought
we could be something special she's back
to Shadowcat apparently Shadowcat has
it's like time-traveling ability to
transport someone's conscious into the
past don't know where she got that power
from but apparently she can do it she's
great super cute why are you gay Ian
McKellen and Patrick Stewart prizes our
roles as the old guys I'm not seeing
them together again especially in this
film cuz you gotta compare like young
magneto and Xavier with old Magneto and
Xavier you get to see the different kind
of chemistry and the performances and
stuff it's really [ __ ] neat really
cool it's Justine McKellen doesn't get
any signature like yelling lines like he
normally does there's so there were
structures but I say we are not sure I
am Charles Xavier I think they both
sound the same yeah there's a bunch of
super badass me too
never good before but just know this
they are badass they are awesome so one
Asian shaped super cute asian chick does
like this thing or Lutz like kind of
teleporting but yeah I don't find us
describe it's like a spark that goes off
it's really neat if you watch the movie
alone I'm talking about Peter Dinklage
was greatest Trask this guy's awesome at
playing midgets his name's Peter
Dinklage like his name is small penis in
a lot of ways I like how they didn't
make you Mike evil there's actual reason
and understanding behind his
philosophies this guy doesn't think he's
a bad guy he literally believes he's
doing something good for America so the
performance of Peter Dinklage just
really did a great job man midgets have
never been more compelling since Willow
there's one flaw for sure that I thought
was they never explained how the [ __ ]
Charles Xavier is back from the dead
you know like I'm sure some people
actually know like the I'm sure some of
you guys are gonna tell me why but still
it's like how I've had it cleared up
please last I saw you were just
disintegrating into a bunch of pieces
like what would happened how are you
alive Captain Picard but at the same
time we didn't really need it for this
story so whatever having Bryan Singer
back for the director seat is awesome I
hope you did not molest that gift don't
have a joke here's really hoped he
didn't do that Simon Kinberg script was
great they knew how to capture the
trauma very well tell a great
character-driven story it's just the
right amount of Menace me cutting back
to 1973 in the apocalyptic future is
kind of a difficult task but it blended
well together in this film by the way
the way they stoled the story of the
future
I was pretty scary man I was like this
is a fucked-up future for sure then I
fight side by side with the mutants you
know it's kind of like you you're cooler
if you find side by side of the mutants
like if you live in California and you
don't like gay people you were hated
that's why I like gays I want to fit in
with the rest of the crowd no gay people
got no problems we get people separate
you Ellen Page change
I used to say it's all time to my
reviews Pattinson it in awhile I usually
say I'll suck someone's dick in the film
but here's what I gotta say this time
around I would totally suck everyone's
dick that was involved with this film
let me get straight to the point here
all I gotta say
x-men Days of Future past got it super
duper [ __ ] Ryan though right
alright guys thanks for checking the
under view for x-men Days of Future past
why don't you go ahead scroll that
comment box below and tell me what would
be the greatest mutant power to use
while having sex and if you want to
follow me on Twitter ah
they said youtubers should you know go
out there interact with their fans more
so I got all this [ __ ] now and walk
throughout they're doing a spoiler
review with hot-ass Lauren gaah oh my
god I would love to make her call on
something if you know what I mean she
doesn't watch this review no last but
not least if you want to get updated
every time one of my reviews or videos
is elcome click on this but about my
dick to subscribe that's right the dick
Lloyd taste something about this little
ex man he has some awesome powers that
have satisfied many ladies in the past
but he has a dark future ahead of him
Blacker's